françois legault semble à court
d'arguments alors qu'il se creuse la
tête pour répondre à une question sur
l'immigration pince conseilleurs
actuellement c'est qu'un déclin le
nombre de québécois qui parlent français
[Applaudissements]
regardent d'abord la situation le
premier ministre n'est pas en mesure de
dire pourquoi la capacité d'accueil du
québec et de 50000 immigrants par année
c'est pourtant le discours qu'il répète
depuis des semaines à l'instar de son
ministre responsable du dossier et le
seuil pour 50 rester
radio-canada a demandé au ministère de
l'immigration de dévoiler les études
qu'il possède à ce sujet deux documents
nous ont été envoyées mais ni l'un ni
l'autre net une étude et aucuns
affirment que la capacité d'accueil du
québec et de 50000 immigrants c'est un
gouvernement qui ne consultent pas les
experts la chef du parti libéral accuse
le gouvernement de faire fi du manque de
main d'oeuvre au québec et surtout du
nombre réel d'immigrants qui s'apprête à
devenir des résidents permanents en 2022
ou québec le chiffre c'est 70 ça veut
donc dire que on est capable
collectivement d'accueillir 70 mille
personnes cette année c'est sans compter
les dizaines de milliers d'autres qui
arrivent avec un statut temporaire
si la capacité d'accueil est vraiment de
50000 immigrants le gouvernement doit
pouvoir le justifier selon des experts
est-ce que c'est problématique
ça pourrait le devenir cet ex directrice
au ministère de l'immigration crois
qu'un vaste forum public sera nécessaire
pour trouver un consensus est-ce qu'on a
regardé le lien entre le nombre de
personnes qui arrivent de l'étranger
peu importe leur statut et
le taux d'occupation
des logements par exemple ou les espaces
en cpe ou les espaces dans les écoles ce
genre de choses là on n'a pas regardé
dans le passé une consultation devait
avoir lieu cette année au québec pour
discuter des seuils d'immigration mais
le gouvernement l'a repoussé à l'an
prochain en raison des élections qui
sont prévues cet automne si alexandre
duval radio canada québec